i can hold coffee cups now you guys i
couldn't last week i was drinking from
straws
you can still kind of see the tops of my
fingers still have weird dots
on your hands well um my hands are
healed uh i mean it's still like you can
see
that that's yeah that's quite sore where
it is i like how it looks like
stigma i like how it looks like on the
right you've got
a healing wound and on the left you were
just being messy with some chocolate
cookies
yeah i've just been eating oreos no
there's bits still there but like the
pink bits really hurt like that's very
tender
um i want to put a pause in that room
but i i don't have to wear nine years
old beat me to it
is the rest of your body made whole by
our lord and savior
my knee is very bad and my arms
um i i feel like i think it was you who
said it last week troy like i'm old like
pulling pants on very difficult it is
extremely painful
like just these parts like my tendons
just
oh not good um lifting milk
still difficult too heavy it's just i'm
still pretty useless but you know i
don't have to whip in
lifting milk is that like the metric of
weight
i left a lot of milk as an australian
hey foreign countries they measure
things in stones i was going to listen
with the stones yeah with you
um with you my favorite i guess that's
the heaviest i guess that's the heaviest
thing that you're lifting on a regular
basis pretty much
like it it's difficult it's still kind
of difficult to open a bottle of water
but
for the most part i'm good is delivery
is delivery milk a thing in australia
oh well not like it is in canada not
like the how they get the bags
wait eggs who delivers milk in a bag
canada
you know paper sack hey friend have you
got your bag of milk yet oh no
because of course it's aardvark day oh
that's a butter
favorite national holiday that we got
there it is a real thing
in bags in canada but it's an abs i
promise you this is a thing
that's a euphemism all right troy i feel
like you should know this i feel like
this is a troy bake effect it has this
written all over it i think it
might come back i don't focus on our our
neighbor to the north
i focus on my neighbor to the far east
or west if you want to keep going that
way everything's east if you go far
enough
mike i need help you are super on brand
what is what is going on look at that
grumpy face mike
do you know about the canadian milk bag
thing
no nickelback my computer by the way
just died i have no idea what you're
talking about oh my god
the world does not want us to make this
podcast today do you know
it never crashes make all of this make
no they get milk delivered in bags is
what i'm
you know the telling canadian milk bag
they
i really love our video game podcast so
much right now it's great right
oh yeah by the way i loaded up hitman
and i just love how fast the ps5 loads
games
listen i was going to say while loads
faster than bags of milk get delivered
that's for sure
especially on that one for [ __ ] sake
um i did want to talk about game demos
this week but i also
am currently obsessed with hitman i
can't
stop thinking about hitman okay i wanted
to start playing it last night with me
start recording oh my god oh my goodness
okay i've started recording
i've recorded for you mike you're fine
thank you i wanted to play this game
last night i got a little bit of time i
was like
hey are you good she's like pam was like
yeah i'm good it's like
travel are you good and he was like hey
man i'm in a great place yeah i'm doing
good dude thanks for asking man
good yeah i think squirrels is like a
little glass of gin
[Laughter]
boysenberry i'm gonna go play some games
it's like cool and
fate went no you're not i was like okay
why not it's like because of something
stupid
like like was like did you push this
button it's like no i didn't push that
button i was like what do we think you
push that button why don't you go look
at youtube videos
for 30 minutes and then never play a
game you broke something
what no i didn't it was just like oh
sorry you were serious about that you
just need to turn this on and turn us
off again
it's that south park thing where the
internet goes down all you have to do is
unplug it and plug it back in
it's literally just like nobody can keep
up with the ps5
it's just dumb it was just it's just
stupid i that's my least
yeah what was the actual problem audio
no audio oh
just because of a button because of a
button not even
because of a button they were like oh no
we're just joking about that
that's very tough background yeah you
guys is this is this hot is troy's
description of what happened to him
confusing the hell out of anyone else
yeah he's really explaining my brain's
broken yes okay cool
just check it out i i have worked very
hard on on my i used to have
real anger issues and because i couldn't
fight physically i would fight verbally
and i would yell that was that was the
model that was given to me is to like
raise my voice
i was like i can't do that so i've
worked really
really hard on on my level of patience
and travelers actually been really
really helpful for that because
a child naturally just pushes your
boundaries of
of patience and so he's taught me how to
be very patient
i still struggle too much
with the if a light
if like a light switch goes here's what
i do my function is this you push this
button and this happens like it if then
right
that heuristic if that is broken
inexplicably
i i i i i'm not in a good i'm not you
mean like
you had one job uh technology not
working
is infuriating inexplicably though
that's the thing you're like well did
you pour water
on your computer it's like yeah like
then that's probably like dude that's my
bad i wish i'll have more
patience with with like a stupid
decision that results in a
and a failure or malfunction rather than
just like um
no of course definitely never get into
programming never use a printer
really that to me all printers are
cursed
pro pro no well programming is like 90
well obviously by definition right
99 of the time when you're coding stuff
it doesn't work
yeah and it doesn't make sense i'm
literally working on
an um spoilers i'm working on like an ai
i'm programming at the moment for a
thing
and it will watch it with this and
it can solve the problem basically
there's a big complex thing in the game
that can work out
its solution to that problem all but
about one percent of the time where it
gives up halfway through
and i have no idea why and i can make it
go through the steps of solving the
problem from that halfway point but yeah
you spend when you're coding it's
you you're intentionally making broken
things and then fixing them until they
work that's how
that's transcoding i've never looked at
it that way because i would think it's
like oh i could show you
exactly why this line of code is wrong
like it's
it seems to me like it would be so i
would imagine that's only true if it's a
very simple program
like one but i bet there's i think
probably as smarter programmers as well
right without being like like faux
modest like definitely there's a tier of
programmer who probably can read code
that way
but no most code tag most programming is
problem solving
is faux modest when you're you have a
fear of missing out of being humble
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's it's uh something that i
i think i would find extremely
frustrating because things not working
for no reason is
is is infuriating it's like my mom
doesn't have a temper
we're very similar um in a lot of ways
but the one thing that will make my mum
just go into a fit of rage is tech not
working
and not knowing why it's like you have
to leave her alone you have to be like i
understand
that the internet is out and i'm very
sorry about that is she fairly tech
savvy no remember the episode where
my parents are [ __ ] useless and they
have to text me what a pdf is
no not text out of events there was one
time where like
what is it like connect stopped working
and i had to leave my connect in
australia when i moved to the us because
it was the only way that they knew how
to use smart apps
was if they could say that the connects
never actually worked in the first place
so it was fine like it was still an
apologist i disagree
i think it's great yeah i really loved
connect
i still remember the connect room we had
at my old work because you
legally you could only have the connect
in a locked office
with uh restricted access so in this
whole game too there was just this one
yeah it was like a hitman level when
they were working on it it was but it
was really restricted and there's like
keypads it was like
and for like the first week everyone
like was like what's in the room
what's in the room that's so protected
and everyone who was working on it was
like i can't say
nda and then second we all realized it
was interesting
when i got red dead redemption 2 early
the nda was like you must have all
windows in your apartment closed
you must have it in a locked box inside
of a locked room like a [ __ ] i live in
the studio i ain't got a lock box
but i have to have a my best you have to
have a member of the uh
what's the what's the like israeli cia
that's it
yes the mossad you have to have a
massage agent on 24
7. thank you i did i did shut all my
windows because there's a neighbor that
is directly across from my windows and i
was like it would suck if
red to cable got leaked because they
shot footage
through their window into my window and
somehow caught my tv somehow
i'd be terrible i think this is
i think this is public knowledge and if
it's not
we're gonna it's gonna be at least the
hell out of this
do you remember the uncharted heist
you mean like playing the game no there
was i remember that some code got out
right
was it got out google to see if there
was a
full you should check if this is let me
check this public
yeah yeah if not we'll deal with all
this this will be
everyone will be like and that's the
craziest thing i've ever heard of that's
when we come back or whatever but
um it happened before shipment hijacked
in transit
okay okay it happened in dover so
they're coming over from france where
they ship
a doesn't matter blue bell's over the
white cliffs of dover it doesn't matter
so i apologize for throwing good yes
he's breaking the sun i'm so sorry
the the the transit was was uh
coming over from france into into dover
and were met with like armored trucks
and they literally hijacked the entire
shipment
and stole the entire shipment
for uncharted for the uk that's some
fast and furious
movies one through three you should
right there do the numbers on that
like you you get it a week early i think
it was
or maybe even maybe even more the street
value of that even if it's just a
hundred pound per that's
i mean you have millions of dollars
worth of product
damn and it was a big deal we were at
the press junket
in rome when that whole thing broke and
they had finally locked it down they're
like yeah we we got all those guys and
it's it's not good but
i was like they they caught up with that
they yeah they caught them
it was not good i guess the i guess the
trophies they got the trophies
the ebay the ebay listing for 10 000
copies of uncharted 4 the next day was
not a good move on their part
they found one in a game studio or in in
a game
store um but the other thing is the
second that you
put that into a ps4
pings hmm it did say they're able to
found in the uk and it's this seems
really nice um
shuhei's statement is basically just
warning people about spoilers he said as
with most naughty dog games you just
love him
he knows that's very shoemaker as with
most of the lovely unfolding story is
such an integral part of the experience
and for this reason we wanted to warn
you to be aware for of the potential
spoilers to be
posted by people with access to stolen
copies of the game it's just like a very
nice
thing to say not being like there was a
goddamn heist
he's like just i hope you all enjoy it
please don't have it spoiled
that's the man that's that's who he is
don't worry about those people you're
seeing that last frame where they're
pushing the boxes like that's where
those people are
okay that's nice that i wonder how
orchestrated it was
uh very i mean if they had all the
vehicles it would be like they knew what
they were stealing they weren't just
going for a truck
they were going for the uncharted
exactly what they were stealing they
knew how to steal they knew the trade
they knew
everything about it wow and they've been
through no
as well right so you want to pre-plan
the whole that's not just sound too much
like someone who's
thought about this but like yeah which
to anyone who might be listening to
thinking of some nefarious plans
noticing mike yeah they they planned
that and executed it
well and it still fails don't try
yeah maybe you don't like when you hear
about it's like when you feel like these
um these like when someone steals like
an original you know
da vinci or van gogh or one of those
kinds of things it's always the same
thing of like
how on earth do you offload that that's
what always trips them up that's
always the point of failure in all of
these plants it's just when i was at ign
the guy came into the building during
the day
waited on the rooftop at night and then
came back down
and robbed ign that's like the denzel
washington
uh what was it how he got inside
at night we were like how on earth
spoilers they figured out that it's that
he went up earlier and then waited up
there and then came back down and i
guess nobody checks the roof but
he stole a bunch of laptops like didn't
get any information they're all locked
it's totally fine
but i remember thinking like we had so
much more expensive equipment than
laptops like a sound board also it was
super easy back in the day to wander
into ign like you could just walk in off
i remember
it did get better even while i was there
but
yeah oh really okay you could kind of
just go up there but uh
uh he stole the laptops because they're
easy to resell that's it it's just you
can resell a laptop super easily there's
so much more valuable stuff in there we
had tons of consoles but even consoles
have serial numbers like it's so much
easier to track down
uh not the laptops don't but to track
down anything that is actually of more
of higher value i feel like if you were
to steal a da vinci
you'd uh you'd just get caught like it's
just no is it have you ever seen
entrapment
the late great sir sean conrad no
and the still great catherine zeta jones
um that talk about how there's like
there's buyers for those things
and it's it's like no we're going to buy
that on the black market and no one's
ever going to come it's like that's the
davinci that was stolen i have it in my
house
wow you need the connections right if
you're going to do that that's the thing
is there's this whole like class
structure amongst
those people because you have to have
the connection you just never tell
anyone
you'd have to like even if you someone
came to your house and saw that painting
like you'd have to want it so bad just
for yourself to never
let anyone that's the thing but that's
the part appreciators it's it's it's
i got that i stole it yeah there's an
episode of uh
next generation uh of a guy like that
and his
his heist is to steal data because he
wants he has like
he has commander yeah well because he
has literally data himself
literally to steal data yeah yeah i i
was making a joke yeah
because he's one of the co-workers we're
in the writer's room but this this idea
was pitched too
no no guys i really mean it's still data
oh it's a great idea
no yeah the idea is that data is like
the most perfect android ever
made that episode and this guy just
wants him for his
collection he he also has like
he also has like van gogh and he's like
the you know this intergalactic
you know sort of black market collector
wow
this is a norbian flock bar you don't
got you've given us
that yep it's a bunch of sort of a man
but again i keep being led to almost
talking about hitman and then not
um so hitman 3 came out got very good
review scores and i have
well actually not played it i've watched
it be played because i haven't been able
to play video games i think today i'm
going to be able to
um but i was recently playing hitman 1
and 2. uh they're like it's not like i
hadn't already played
it but i dropped off because they were
episodic and used to release maps bit by
bit so i had only played like one or two
and not played more than that
man they're good they're all so good
played this new
since they rebooted it though i haven't
played it so like
this isn't hitman three it's like it's
hit man like seven it's the third game
in in this car
yeah in this trilogy yeah and the last
presumably if they're on to bomb now
probably this is it
which you know i it's not like i ever
had any doubt that they could do bond
but after playing the
level that you tweeted about mike the
second level of hitman 3
it's just damn it's gonna be a good bond
game which troy's in
troy plays a photographer amen i mean
level two of hitman three you don't it's
fine he's not forgotten
i didn't talk to the photographer oh no
it's just a very similar to the point
that's what's funny is like he's in
every game i'm like i'm i can tell you
games that uh more games that i'm not in
than i am well yeah although i although
the fact that you have to make that
proviso implies that you're in a lot of
games
and i and i will i will say i watched
quite a few people
streaming uh the pathless
where they finish the game credits start
to roll
and i see all these like i especially
loved watching the non-english speakers
i didn't know
i got to the credits yes i literally
freaked out i was like [ __ ] that was
troy
yeah it's so funny troy troy and laura
both and the fact that people are like
you know sitting there and it's like
don't you try baker
he's got me again he's doing it again
but
do something on the internet um i think
that uh
mikey we're talking about hitman 3 being
very good i just i just want to say i
agree i don't know
about paul speaking he was complimenting
pathless how dare you rob us
hitman 3 is also excellent i still do
need to play about this i'd really like
to but um
this is like the family guy of kermit
ray romano and whoever else all talking
over each other on the news
if i can say something about the
pathless i don't know
i shared this with austin it is the most
flawlessly beautiful poetic
satisfying that the gameplay is just so
satisfying it's just so simple
it was as meditative as i wanted ghost
of sushima to be
but by the very nature of its own
function could not
like there was always someone trying to
fight you bear shows up
there's just yeah there's a bunch of
stuff in the world and and pathless
doesn't have that it's like
look up on the horizon and wherever you
see red there's a bear
there's a bear there's deer there's all
sorts of stuff but it's just it was so
it never got repetitive
it was just so wonderfully
beautiful and it's it's fine i love that
it was content to be
a poem rather than an epic as well like
there was like
four hours and we're done and i love
that about it and i appreciate there's
lots more content if you want it but
like
i just i thought it was perfectly
structured to what it was and i thought
yeah
very i started to go back through and
play it again first of all i did play it
on apple tv
really you didn't mention so are you
playing that on the remote or
no you have to pair my my controller my
ps4 controller to it
um which it does very very seamlessly uh
and i also played it on my iphone
um i assumed you were playing it on ps5
i had no idea
you no i did play it on ps5
so you're lying you play it twice yeah
i've i've played it i finished it on ps5
lana doesn't trust you anymore
and i also started it on on iphone
because i just wanted to see how
differently it played and it
played three times yeah i assume there's
no cross save
which
and i see it's still blowing my mind you
can now play something on
ps4 and then play it on xbox series x
and then play it on pc on your same save
file
i think supergiant got that up and
running on hades also because really
i think so i started playing hades as
well
very good game it's a lot
it's a lot at once
just like roguelikes in general like
roguelikes in general
right at that kind of bombarding with
information the first play through and
then you kind of
hating something better than that
actually similar to hitman similar to
hitman yes
interesting i i think it's the first of
all anything that darren does
i i'm a fan of and it felt
it felt like a very much of a call back
to
like some old capcom games if it it it
threw back to like some arcade like
it i i love that style of of game
it's just been a minute since i've
played one
and i was like oh it's it's like it's
like it's a different language
um and even like graphically what's
happening on screen
and then mechanically what's happening
was like man it's been a second since
i've played
a game like this before so i understood
the appeal of everyone going
[ __ ] i've missed and it's not saying
like this is the first game that's been
out you know since the 90s whatever
there's many iterations of it but it's
done very very well
but it was like i'm tempted to go in and
a friend of mine made a comment where uh
i was like i'm tempted to play god mode
he's like well aren't you kind of always
in god mode
it's like because you're lame joke
i enjoyed it i enjoy it you got smoke
from me thank you let the audio
listeners know that i smiled at your
joke
yes yeah noticed it's kind of a charity
smile i think it was no it wasn't a
sincere one
so yeah i've i've been wanting to get
into hitman 3 but is what what are you
what's the comparison you're drawing
between
um just that hitman the loop of hitman i
adore
and every single time i re i start a new
one
or come back to it as long as i said
because definitely with with hitman one
where it was like
episodic and was two like that as well
two wasn't right two all came out once
yeah i think two all came out at once
other than like the dlc yeah the great
thing about hitman is you go into an
environment it's so
dense and so many overlapping mechanics
and stories you go into an environment
and you're
immediately overwhelmed every single
hitman level i start i'm like
it's just impossible it's too
complicated it's too big they're so big
it's so big and so confusing and why why
have they messed up hitman
and then you play it and the great thing
about hitman especially in the
new trilogy trilogies they emphasize the
idea of no you're not going to play this
level once you're going to loop through
it
and try different approaches so you know
i took the day off work yesterday and i
played just just the first mission of
the new hitman
um which is up this beautiful skyscraper
in dubai
and i think i must have played that
level through like five or six
times and by the end you're like um
you're like bill murray in groundhog day
you're just like
doing that knowing exactly when that
guy's gonna come out that door and just
kind of it's and
that process of going from being
completely overwhelmed to absolute
mastery
yeah that's good so satisfying and how
quickly it can happen
like it can be an hour like the paris
level of hitman 1
is probably one of my least favorites if
i'm being honest um but that level
you're like there is no way that i can
kill these two people it is just not
going to happen but then you find out
that there are like five different ways
okay he he's here at this point could i
get maybe
should i get his bodyguards get up is
that it but then he'll recognize me
probably and one thing that i really do
like about those games is that if you're
wearing
um a disguise anyone who would be like
your manager
will recognize you that there are laws
to who will recognize you and who won't
they'll be like i don't work with that
dude that's not what he looked like what
the hell's happened to your face so you
have to figure out okay which of these
people would know who i
am am i going to be able to get into
even this building because there's um
another one in hitman 1.
i think it's it's marrakech where there
are two buildings in a big open area
between them and you have to get under
both of them in completely different
ways they're just
they're so fun but i really like that
hitman 3
uh again especially with that second
level
basically has like this case for you to
solve
but technically you don't have to that
just when i was playing that i was just
like this this is the bond game that i
want and i know that
the hitman games like the those last
three have all been designed to be
bond-esque anyway they were saying that
they
set them in places specifically that you
should want to go to
like it's a bond film like this set the
settings are places that
i mean their design is beautiful like
when i'm walking around those games i'm
always like whoever got to design this
room like it's just
they're so pretty but it's supposed to
be you shouldn't want to go there
okay well i have a question then so if
you get
you know tapped to take over such a
well-known or well-loved franchiser
especially one that's been iterated on
for literally
over 50 years
do you want that to be like oh it's it's
hitman with the bond skin or or
i'm so i would say this if you weren't
here mike
but like the pitch for john wick
is a shooter or it's a third-person
over-the-shoulder action adventure
combination melee shooter that's that's
what the pitch should be
not oh it's essentially
turn-based strategy completely i think i
think you've nailed it troy i think i
made a terrible mistake
but you want to me like anybody else
going i was like well sure you go do
that it's like
or what you do is you flip the genre
and you use you invoke the the moniker
and the world and you show that it is
maybe this is a good example maybe it's
not but
i whenever i wrote a song i would always
instantly hear the drums i would hear
the strings i would have the horns or
the choir hair and everything else
and wayne miller producer that i worked
with his incredible producer he's like
what is that song on an acoustic guitar
around the fire
that is a good song when you have lyrics
and melody that's the song and if you
can have a great song that can be played
just on piano or just on
on an acoustic guitar then it's a good
song so if it requires all of those big
things it's probably not a good song
so if i hear that that fully endorsed
this statement
huh i fully endorse this statement cool
cool
[Laughter]
are people going to be going oh i
understand why they got the bond gig
because this is basically hitman
but it's james bond in other words are
you hoping
it's i am making bond that does it for
me like it's the studio
so it would be like you know those
questions it's like who would you have
make this
in in my head it is i are making bond it
doesn't mean that i want it to be
hitman bond edition um and i'm sure
they'll evolve it and they've proven
that over the last three hitman games
that they do take steps to evolve each
one of them they're not the same game
and they very easily could be because
hitman's been around for so long
and has had similar formulas so you put
the poison in the drink and the guy dies
like
they could have just kept doing that but
i i think that like i don't i don't
doubt that they will probably have more
combat for
bond is what i would expect i think yeah
sorry i think i think yeah i think
there's kind of there's two approaches
which well sorry there's three
approaches one is like what i think
people maybe think was going through my
head with john wick when we did when we
did do a turn-based genre game
which is you can just go well screw this
i'm gonna do something completely
different and original and and
you know screw the franchise i'm gonna
do whatever i think is right and i think
that's a terrible way to approach ip i
would never do that
but i do think i do think with ip you
can kind of do two one or two things you
can either lean in
to what the obvious answer to the
problem is which yeah like with john
wick would be a third person action game
with with james bond as well i guess a
third person action game plus driving
mechanics
is the obvious kind of solution which is
why there's so many of those james bond
games out there
but i think the thing that we tried to
do with john wick and i what i
expect given how good i think io are
then to do is actually to find uh and
this i think is a good way of adapting
anything
find their angle on something they're
still true to the thing
but focus is on the aspect of the thing
that they find interesting so with john
wick we were
i love john wick because i love watching
that level of technical choreography and
i was interested i thought there's a
game in that
and with james bond and you know if
someone's not played hitman you said
troy you've not played the the new
trilogy of hitman like
hitman is now i i think i said it was
called it was like clockwork theater
right
and i said on tour the other day it's
totally true it is it's a play
there is a play happening on stage and
you are an actor who's gone in
and you've not been given a script
everyone else is doing their part and
the first time you go through it you're
flailing trying to work out what to do
in that world
by the end you're the actor who's
heisting the play and choosing how to
reorient the play to get what you want
that is an excellent description of how
james
bond walks into a room there's social
interaction there's manipulation
there is violence there's action there's
there's all of that as well but when i
think about what james blonde does
in the kind of quintessential james bond
although never go back and reconcile
royale that book has aged [ __ ]
terribly
i did that last week last year and boy
howdy
um that is the very very first book
the first one yeah casino royale you go
back tonight this is definitely
this is probably like a horrible
misogynist book for its time it's not
aged don't read this
crazy phil said that he thinks that like
he doesn't like bond because he's just a
horrible misogynist
i think he's been very cool and if you
read i mean the
the yeah casino royale literally the
internal monologue is always referring
to the vespa character as
a [ __ ] like just that's how even like
when they're falling in love
it's a it's a there's i love it if you
look
if you look at like what casino royale
is and if you look at the movie the
the the daniel craig movie of it like
that is a that is a hitman level in so
far as it's a character walking into a
room and having mastery over the social
and action elements of that so yeah i'm
i agree i don't think they're just going
to take hitman and re-skin it but that
method i'm just hoping it's a magical
mobile game
maybe it will be but i think i think you
can take that kind of i o approach to
kind of problem solving that kind of
immersive sim
a big scale that kind of level design
disrupting force
yeah their level design that sense of
place which has always been a big part
of the bond movies in particular not so
much i guess the books but in the movies
they were tourism like the bond movies
were designed on some level
to be shown to a predominantly western
audience as tourism to places that those
audiences probably couldn't afford to go
and couldn't afford to experience it
makes sense again it makes perfect like
this is a the locations will make sense
i want to go to the casino royale's bond
and be given the objective of getting uh
it's just to get to the
sheath right and be thrown open so like
i could do that via the card game i
could
take out some of his goo like there you
can you can start to think how the other
thing that's really interesting just for
getting bond for a second
i love the idea of that team and that
level design being applied to a game
which has more verbs and more potential
objectives than kill people
like i'm sure obviously there'll be
action but like and it's not even a
moralistic thing but like you're
definitely
starting especially in three and
especially in that second mission
to feel the designers hitting the
constraints of oh it's hitman we have to
do an assassination
hitman 3 the second chapter i don't want
to spoil it for anyone who's not played
yet but there is
there is a very obvious opportunity to
do a cool thing
and when you i i well you don't have to
say the case
you don't have to do it if you choose to
do it if you choose to do it well it's
like an hour and a half
long yeah the process of going around
doing all the things
and then finding out all the different
ways you can play with that information
how you can use that to socially
probably finish that level in 20 minutes
if you
really want to maybe i mean the silent
assassin like you can get through
most of the maps in the hitman level in
the game game usually in about 10
minutes if you not me
exactly but that's the but when you're
on loop five you start to do the
groundhog day play and that's amazing
but yeah that's i can feel that design
team is capable of doing stuff without
the constraint of what people expect
from a hitman game and i'm excited to
see them yeah and and without this
constrain of golden eye which is such an
interesting thing because it's a
franchise where you have one of the most
beloved games of all time already
sure so exactly who wants to follow that
right yeah
i have a follow-up question because
we've seen this a lot in film
where all right director you've proven
yourself
with your own little things christopher
nolan did it
ryan johnson did it j.j abrams did it
there have been all of these directors
who are like now we're going to hand you
the mantle of this established ip to put
your thing on
to to iterate uh upon it as you will
games have done the same thing we're
going to give this studio
this moniker or this this ip
is do you think that is the goal of
a studio is to be able to that's when
you've quote made it
is to be given the is that the
the thing that studios should be working
towards is
it's a goal but i'm saying like that's
when you know you've made it like
they're gonna do
because look i mean like you said i
always had this long pedigree
but it's like they're going to do bond
and
or i mean lucas you know coming back and
doing
indiana jones makes sense there's a
lineage to that
but whenever someone said you know um
it's like i want to see naughty dog do
that game it's like
it's not like i want to see them come up
with something new but we always i i see
this tendency for
a general public to go i want to see
this thing be made by that studio
is it do you think that's like the ap
the general public's
job is not to come up with cool ideas
that's all of our jobs right like i
i don't begrudge the audience wanting
more of something they know they like
already
but in terms of like objectives yeah i
think i mean we've we've done we
we just did a license game and i'm not
spoiling anything i think by saying we
probably will go back and do other ip
stuff at some point
because it's interesting because you get
to kind of collaborate with interesting
creative people you get to learn from
stuff
as a designer as well it's great to have
that shorthand we all know what bond is
so that gets
that cuts out so much of the work for io
in terms of teaching you how to play the
game because you're gonna play it like
you're james bond there's gonna be a
there's there's a really interesting set
of cultural theming that you can lean on
and kind of give you the opportunity
the other thing is financial security
which honestly i don't
know io as a company but like i i know
that they've struggled for years to like
make the commercial case
for hitman because it's such a brilliant
game that doesn't
really seem to like have phenomenal
numbers so i imagine attaching
what the kind of design they love to do
to something which they know will
have that kind of visibility and in
theory do good numbers
does make sense but it's a goal it's not
no i i would be
astonished if naughty diet dog ever did
a license game because why would they
what do they get from that what's the
objective what's the
what's the problem that's solving for
naughty dog an indie studio like mine
doing a big ip
of course yeah there's lots of very good
business reasons and there's also
opportunities to learn
the insomniac spider-man thing's
interesting because
they arguably didn't have to do a
spider-man game but i
bet they just really wanted to wanted to
yeah i i know there's also they've been
leaning in that direction for
for a while right so that ip made sense
for the kind of game they wanted
which is also a way of doing this this
isn't just the case that iep holders
will go
we want to make a game of our thing
you're a cool studio do it often
i've been in the situation where i've
been out you know e3 or gdc this
literally happened to me once
i was out pitching a concept for a game
and
talking to everyone in town about it and
someone i showed it to
just said oh that's a perfect fit for
this french this big franchise ip
and set up a meeting and there was an
opportunity there to take that
mechanic that we had and and work with
an ip that
fit that and make a game it didn't come
together in the end that wasn't a thing
that happened but like it can go that
way as well you've got the game design
and then you find the ip that matches it
rather than being reactive just to the
ip and that can be captured for everyone
i was i was actually just about to float
that exact scenario because i have some
good friends who are working on a game
that that is
that is precisely what happened they
were working for like a year
or more on a thing that was an original
ip of their own
um but the underlying architecture you
know
made its way in front of certain
shareholders of certain ip and said
you know what if this was our narrative
universe but everything like you just
reskinned what you're doing basically to
our thing and they said
okay and they they literally did that
they literally made a deal which happens
all the time in movies right
the number of movies where 10 questions
are lost to franchises
10 cloverfield lane there's also like oh
what was i was watching the other day
where i was like was that not originally
was that movie like written as a
standalone like
a movie filmed
to kind of join things up that's the and
so that's one way but it happens with
screenplays right all the time like if
you're
a jobbing writer in in la and you've got
a screenplay for like
an awesome action movie that's that's
about a heroic
guy who does a cool thing in like a spy
context there's a non-zero chance that
that will just be picked up by a studio
to be
transformed into the next men in black
or the next mission impossible
i think i don't think that that doesn't
have a mission impossible so much
because
anymore but like there were there are
definitely sequels to movies
where they've taken i mean a good the
best example of this would be um
didn't this happen with pirates of the
caribbean
but on stranger tides so on stranger i
think it's called on stranger tides
which one of the parts of the caribbean
movies
that was a book there's a pirate story
book called
on stranger tights has nothing to do
with prior to the caribbean they buy the
rights to the book
develop that as a and they roll it in
because that's easier
and more reliable than getting a writer
to come in and invent something from
whole cloth
so there's so this happens all over the
shop like these kind of reworkings of
things
an ip has value and you know insures
bombs or seats not necessarily the most
creative approach would be awesome if
everything was originally new
they say we're not doing much
well i mean if the audience watching
this are more likely to pick up a game
from me if it's tied to an ipv they
they're fans of that's something they've
just been proven time and again however
much they say oh we want we don't want
stuff that's tied to a franchise
yeah you do look at your shelf like you
do and and that's
that's kind of okay and if that's so
well people love conspiracies
they love because there is something
solid there is something
there it is it is it is funny how we we
we [ __ ] and moan about the lack of new
ideas uh and then
even even and then yeah even as i
as someone everything on my show i'll
never forget i was at a movie theater
once
and they're rolling the trailers before
it starts
and it was like black screen and then
a little flash of static with like radio
chatter of
what sounds like chaos in a battlefield
or something and then and then out so
just a split second
and then pause silence
another thing and then you know
it's just getting a little bit more and
then and then the static flicker started
to go
just like china
and then it you know full on boom boom
boom boom
full on you know new tran uh terminator
movie coming
and i was like [ __ ] if that's not what
if someone else said
someone watching this has to get the
footage of that train
dab it with what you just did
i want a guaranteed retweet if someone
says
um i devastatingly have to go i have a
meeting uh this is our show
i'm just glad we got into demo yeah i
know it always happens i don't know why
i even
helping city well to be fair i wanted to
talk about hitman but um yeah our
shortest episode of all time i think
because
it took 45 minutes to get going
technical challenges
go play hitman that would be that would
be right also you want to introduce us
before we leave yeah that's what i
figured i should do hi everyone welcome
to another episode of play watch listen
i'm alana video game writer that's troy
baker video game actor that's
mike bithell video game director and
that's austin wintry
austin
video game composer um we will see you
all
austin austin austin final four
there he is